good evening welcome to a special
edition of Tucker Carlson tonight
according to new numbers over the
weekend the Democratic primary race is
constricting to become really a two-man
contest a lot of people still in the
race but the outline of the future is
getting clear so in one side you have a
candidate Bernie Sanders who wants to
turn this country into a comprehensive
welfare state he plans to upend every
aspect of American life in order to
impose a new economic order now Sanders
isn't hiding what he plans to do he's
running on what he plans to do his main
rival is Michael Bloomberg the former
mayor of New York Bloomberg has shot to
above 15% nationally in the polls from
nowhere essentially he's suddenly
leading the race in the critical Super
Tuesday state of Florida so what is Mike
Bloomberg running on that's a trick
question actually Bloomberg isn't
running on anything not because he
doesn't have ideas he's got plenty of
ideas and some of them are far outside
the American mainstream but Bloomberg
doesn't think any of that matters he's
not running on ideas he's not trying to
convince voters of anything he's not
making arguments or working to change
their minds on policies they care about
he's trying to buy them and hence the
presidency it's the single most cynical
political campaign ever run in this
country Bloomberg is trying to subvert
our democracy with cash and he's going
all-in to do it according to the latest
numbers Bloomberg has spent more than
417 million dollars on advertising so
far in this race his nearest rival
Bernie Sanders has spent 40 million
that's less than 1/10 Joe Biden the man
they told us was the front runner has
spent just 12 point three million
compare that let's say it again to the
at least 417 million Bloomberg is pumped
into the race just on advertising and
that's just the beginning
aides say Bloomberg is willing to spend
2 billion dollars of his own money by
Election Day and the number could go
higher nothing like this has ever
happened in America
Bloomberg spending is like in pick your
metaphor here a tsunami breaking over
our political system when the waters
recede there's nothing left it's been
flattened and wiped clean by the weight
of Mike Bloomberg's wealth Bloomberg is
the tallest figure on the landscape the
only one left upright that's his plan
he's all but admitted that's his plan
watch him hear disavows
and frisk the single most successful
policy he had as mayor of New York I
defended it looking back for too long
because I didn't understand then the
unintended pain it was causing to young
black and brown families and their kids
I heard their pain their confusion and
their anger and I've learned from them
and I've grown from them so think about
what you just saw it's not the normal
pandering Mike Bloomberg believes
passionately in gun control it's his
life's missions is signature issue stop
and frisk may have been the most
effective gun control policy ever
administered anywhere it took thousands
of illegal firearms off the streets of
New York
but Democratic primary voters have
decided they don't like it there again
stop and frisk so without even pausing
Bloomberg gravels as you just saw and
attacks his own legacy why did he do
that because he doesn't care whatever
their only words he'll do whatever it
takes
now they say politicians are ethically
flexible and of course they are but this
is different there's something ominous
about it Bloomberg can seamlessly change
his core beliefs because he doesn't
think his beliefs are relevant to the
outcome of this race only his wealth
matters and the horrifying fact is he
may be right how wealthy is Michael
Bloomberg well for context the richest
of the fabled Russian oligarchs Lee
annoyed Mickelson is worth about twenty
four billion dollars Michael Bloomberg
could literally give away twice that
amount or spend it on a presidential
race if he wanted and still be five
times as rich as Donald Trump is it's
hard to imagine just how much money that
is but with that money
Bloomberg can suffocate all opposition
and seize power a ruling class which
worships money above all sees nothing
wrong with this the Rieger to help
Bloomberg do it like Bloomberg there
religiously libertarian on economic
matters that's a position that's shared
by only a tiny percentage of the
population no normal person in this
country thinks the widening wealth gap
is a good thing it's so obviously making
America unstable but Mike Bloomberg has
been one of its chief beneficiaries he
will defend the current system above all
else there's a reason he's the favorite
of finance moguls and tech comma stars
again this is a total
departure from anything we have seen
before in the history of this country
say what you will about Donald Trump but
in 2016 he ran for president on ideas
that large numbers of voters actually
likes whether or not they liked him
secure the border and counterproductive
Wars fight the fascism of political
correctness in selling those ideas he
spent about half with Hillary Clinton's
spent but Bloomberg can't be bothered
with selling ideas or with a platform he
doesn't care what the public thinks
that's why he believes he can win oh by
overwhelming voters with his money this
is the nightmare scenario that campaign
finance reform activists used to tell us
about and they'll write about one thing
our system has been vulnerable to people
like Michael Bloomberg for a long time
he's just the first one who's actually
tried to do it you should be alarmed by
his campaign for president democracy
doesn't break when voters choose
unwisely they sometimes do democracy
collapses when what voters want becomes
irrelevant